hey guys so this really quick video is
to serve two purposes firstly as an
experiment because I love me some
experimenting and secondly as an update
firstly the update at the moment I'm
working on two videos first as a result
of my 10,000 subscriber video instantly
as all the time of recording I'm working
on a draw my life video that's probably
to take a little while because it's just
a video that takes a lot of preparation
so please be patient and secondly I'm
also working on a video which will
hopefully be out either next week or the
week after which tries to explain the
actual science there the physics of
global warming in less than two minutes
again I'm you're doing some animation
stuff about so it's gonna take a little
while but I'm gonna try and get out for
next week I'm sorry that there hasn't
been as much content recently there's
been a couple of weeks so there hasn't
been a video but life has been crazy
busy I'm now at my new house and because
it's an unfurnished house we had to sort
out a lot of stuff also I was doing some
videos for this in Peters collared
YouTube channel and also some videos for
the oxblood project so it's been a bit
busy recently but hopefully this is
gonna be back on track incidentally if
you're a person who is watching this
video and it's coming to Oxford this
October for the first time we are
looking for people like you to take part
in the oxblood project if you don't know
about that is a collaborative video
blogging project that I started two
years ago and we're looking for new
people because the current hob-knockers
a lot of them are moving onto other
things and we need some freshers there's
gonna be a video on the Oxbow channel
which I'll leave a link to in the
description in a couple of days time
explaining how you can apply to be part
of the project I'd really encourage you
if you'd like to take part in the
project to apply and there's gonna be
more information on that scene so please
stay tuned the second part there in the
experiment so I I wanted to do a little
experiment on youtuber audience
interactions now if you haven't watched
niccola's videos on this subject he
doesn't awful lot of really good stuff
I'll leave a link to his channel in the
description um I I but I I was thinking
about this earlier this week about the
fact that you guys always tune in and
watch my vlogs and watch what my life's
been like and the most-watched vlogs of
all are the day in the life you know
it's like a slap shot into what somebody
else's life is like but you know what
that about me I'm at interaction there's
one way because I know nothing about
what you guys are like I know nothing
about you apart from your name of your
channel and the comments you leave so
I want to know from you leave a comment
on this video saying what you've been up
to today how your days been maybe a week
if something interesting happened and
that could be a sentence it could be a
paragraph it could be an essay I want to
hear about you guys I want to know who
you are
so tell me how's your day been how you
getting on I'm really looking forward to
seeing what you guys say because I want
to know I want to know about you guys
but hopefully you'll be seeing me in a
more formal video next week thank you
very much for watching